Jurassic World is back in a huge way with
new dinosaurs, Baby Blue and Ian Malcolm himself
in the first full trailer for Fallen Kingdom.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm breaking down the Jurassic World
2 trailer for easter eggs, things you missed
and explaining the new dinosaurs you can look
forward to in the movie!
And if you're new to my channel, I do movie
breakdowns, easter eggs, deleted scenes and
movie-making secrets, as well as regular giveaways
for all my subscribers.
For my current giveaway, just make sure you're
subscribed and leave me a comment on this
video with your thoughts about Fallen Kingdom.
I'll have more details on that plus the winner
of my last giveaway later in the video.
The trailer begins with Owen and Claire who
are setting up a task force to save the dinosaurs
left on the island from a dormant volcano
that's about to explode.
Claire is putting together a new organization
called the Dinosaur Protection Group and,
in the trailer, we get a glimpse of some of
the group's other key members.
We've got a new young scientist played by
Justice Smith, and it's rumoured he's playing
a character inspired by Arby Benton from author
Michael Crichton's second Jurassic Park novel.
In another shot, we get a glimpse of Ted Levine's
character who seems to be dressed in combat
gear and behind him is Daniella Pineda's character.
We don't yet have names for their characters,
but in a picture of Pineda released in a behind-the-scenes
trailer reel, you can see she's got a tattoo
which partially reads "Semper Fi", which is
the US Marine Corps motto, meaning she's likely
either from the US military or she's a former
marine.
We then get to the island where it's clear
that, since the events of Jurassic World,
the theme park is more or less in ruins and
dinosaurs are roaming freely.
By the way, the official synopsis states that
the sequel is actually set 4 years after the
first Jurassic World movie.
And back from Jurassic World is our favourite
raptor Blue who, at the end of that movie,
disappeared into the jungle after helping
Rexy defeat the Indominus.
Also in this next shot of Blue reuniting with
Owen, there's an abandoned old explorer from
the original Jurassic Park movie in the background.
Earlier in the trailer, there was also an
adorable short scene of Owen with Baby Blue.
We don't yet know where this comes in the
film, however, I think this might be some
old video of Owen raising baby Blue and imprinting
on her, which he talked about doing in Jurassic
World.
And I think this footage might get played
if Owen gives testimony at this committee
meeting where we see none other than Ian Malcolm
himself!
Now, we did get some Ian Malcolm easter eggs
in Jurassic World, but this is the moment
a lot of fans of the franchise have been waiting
for and, of course, Jeff Goldblum even gets
to deliver his classic line "life finds a
way".
He's in what looks like either a US government
senate hearing or a courtroom, and I imagine
he's been called upon as an expert witness,
presumably to comment on the events of Jurassic
World or perhaps to advise what to do about
the dinosaurs still at large on Isla Nublar.
That seems rather ironic because, in the original
movies, when Malcolm tried to tell the public
about what had happened at Jurassic Park,
he was discredited by John Hammond's nephew,
made a laughing stock, and his career was
ruined.
We don't yet know from the limited lines we
hear in the trailer whether Malcolm is for
or against saving the dinos on the island.
Although this is the only scene we've seen
of him so far, I'm hoping we see him pop up
at least once again, though he might just
have a small role appearing near the start
and the end of the movie, like John Hammond
did in The Lost World.
OK, let's get back to the island where we're
going to see some of the new dinosaurs and
some more call-backs to the original Jurassic
Park.
When we see Claire and her crew hiding behind
some tree trunks from a herd of charging dinos,
it's an homage to that memorable scene in
the first Jurassic Park movie of Dr Grant
and the children hiding behind a tree trunk
to avoid a dinosaur stampede.
And just at this moment we get our first look
at the Carnotaurus, a new dinosaur for the
sequel.
The Carnotaurus, which means "meat-eating
bull", has two horns above its eyes, and,
fun fact, genetic material from the Carnotaurus
was used for the creation of the hybrid Indominus
Rex in the first Jurassic World.
Now, this is one pretty mean-looking dino
but just as it seems to be about to take out
Owen and the others, Rexy swoops in and saves
the day.
And if you're thinking that there seems to
be something familiar about this scene, it's
because it's clearly a tribute to the final
scene in Jurassic Park where the T-Rex roars
after saving the adults and kids from the
velociraptors.
Another new dinosaur which was only hinted
at in Jurassic World, but which we're getting
properly in Fallen Kingdom, is the Baryonyx.
The name refers to the "heavy, large claw"
on the dino's first finger, and it was going
to be the original primary antagonist in the
third Jurassic Park movie, until it was replaced
by the Spinosaurus.
And it looks like the Baryonyx will make a
spectacular appearance during an underground
scene in what is probably a control room for
an old power plant on the island.
You can see fire and lava flowing, so it looks
like this scene takes place around the time
the volcano begins to erupt.
We know now that Rexy is back for the sequel
and, in another shot, we can see she's been
sedated and loaded into a truck.
And although we see what looks like a lot
of dinosaurs probably perishing from the volcano
eruption, there are a few shots earlier in
the trailer that show what looks like a boat,
loaded with dinosaurs, leaving the island.
Now, if you're concerned you've seen most
of the movie's plot, rest assured that these
scenes are actually only from the first half
of the movie and are, in a sense, the set-up
for the main plot of the film.
The official synopsis has actually stated
that Claire and Owen uncover "a conspiracy
that could return our entire planet to a perilous
order not seen since prehistoric times."
Which means, I think, that there's a plot
going on to bring these dinosaurs off the
island and to the mainland.
InGen will likely be involved in this together
with Henry Wu who we didn't get to see in
this trailer.
Dr Wu was last seen in Jurassic World on an
InGen helicopter making off with a bunch of
dinosaur DNA from the park, however, in the
Fallen Kingdom behind-the-scenes reel, we
did get a brief glimpse of Wu who's definitely
cooking up a new hybrid, the Indo-raptor,
which I expect we'll see later in the film.
By the way, all the footage released so far
suggests we're getting a much bigger push
for animatronic dinosaurs in Fallen Kingdom.
Practical effects were a big part of the original
Jurassic Park movie, whereas the first Jurassic
World movie only used animatronics in a single
scene with a dying Apatosaurus.
The animatronics development on the sequel
has been spearheaded by Neal Scanlan, whose
creature designs you'll have seen in the new
Star Wars movies.
Animatronics will be limited mostly to close-up
shots, with CGI enhancing some elements, but
from what's been teased so far it looks good.
Now, what did you think of the first full
trailer for Fallen Kingdom?
Were you a fan of the first movie and has
the new trailer got you hyped for the sequel?
Let me know what you think.
For chance to win a cool Funko Pop, make sure
you leave a comment below about the trailer
and subscribe to my channel.
The winner of my recent giveaway is on screen
right now and if that's you, make sure you
send me a private message with your details
so I can get the prize out to you.
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
you hitting that like button, and don't forget
to turn on notifications to get all my new
videos, plus you can check out some more videos
you're sure to like here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!